estos residentes enfermos son
cuidadosamente trasladados en camillas a
estas embarcaciones la única forma de
sacarlos de la ciudad
mientras las fuerzas ucranianas avanzan
las autoridades de ocupación rusa han
pedido a los civiles que abandonen
gerson los pasajeros se sientan en un
tenso Silencio en el agua no habría
ningún lugar donde refugiarse en las
orillas opuestas más lejos de la línea
del frente los transbordadores van y
vienen transportando cientos de
pasajeros llevando todo lo que pueden
cargar
no hay disparos Aquí no hay disparos
donde vamos
mientras asumen la pérdida de casi todo
lo que poseen
el auto todas mis pertenencias no me
queda nada
esta residente y su familia están
convencidos de que emprenden un viaje
sin retorno la casa donde han vivido
toda su vida fue bombardeada
ya no tenemos casa a donde volveríamos
nuestra casa se quemó volver a donde
Cómo puedo explicarlo ya no sabemos A
quién temer ya llevamos siete meses
viviendo bajo amenaza donde están
disparando quién está disparando
los que no saben a dónde ir Son
evacuados por los rusos que controlan
los alrededores pues aunque todos son
ciudadanos ucranianos los llevan a Rusia
con mi patria es Ucrania Pero esto es
temporal
Juan Gabriel pero la mayoría de los que
van dicen que apoyan a los rusos
es rusa volveremos si es ucraniana
Entonces no
todos los residentes con los que
hablaron los periodistas de France dicen
que no se vieron obligados a abandonar
gerson y algunos incluso optaron por
quedarse